[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue sur les plateformes du
figaro pour évoquer l'actualité et vos
points de vue sur l'actualité et quand
je dis vous je pense à vous qui nous
suivait sur internet ou sur les réseaux
sociaux mais aussi à mes deux invités de
ce vendredi 19 février
tout d'abord guillaume bernard maître de
conférences à l'institut catholique
d'études supérieures de vendée à la
roche sur yon vous publier régulièrement
des textes très fins d'analysé politique
et vous est notamment l'auteur d'un
livre qui reste bigrement d'actualité en
tout cas son titre la guerre à droite
aura bien lieu
le mouvement dextrogyre publié aux
éditions desclée de brouwer avec nos six
ferghana ziari chargé d'études à
l'institut de recherche économique et la
concurrence fiscale délégué général de
l'académie libre des sciences humaines
grandes voies du libéralisme économique
et politique dont on peut lire les
opinions dans le figaro bugs dans le fil
rq box et dans le point entre autres
alors sur quoi allez-vous débattre
dialoguer peut-être vous disputer
aujourd'hui tout d'abord peut-être sur
la question de nos libertés qui selon
certains à gauche mais pas seulement
sont de plus en plus menacé par les
mesures prises par le gouvernement pour
contrôler la crise sanitaire vous nous
direz si vous partagez cette crainte
nous chausserons ensuite treillis et
casques lourds de combat pour évoquer un
sujet que l'actualité récente a remises
en lumière déployées sur plusieurs
continents et sur plusieurs théâtres
d'opérations la france at-elle vraiment
encore les moyens de ses ambitions
militaires
on commence d'abord avec cette question
qui devient de plus en plus centrale
dans notre france soumise au couvre feu
nos libertés réduite pour des raisons
sanitaires sont elles durablement menacé
le gouvernement comme étant une sorte d'
abus de pouvoir en profitant de la
situation
cette petite musique se fait de plus en
plus entendre hier par exemple dix
députés de la république en marche
regroupés dans un sou parti qui
s'appelle en commun avec notamment
barbara pompili ont adressé un courrier
à jean castex dénonçant la poursuite de
l'état d'urgence sanitaire pour encore
quatre mois qu'ils prolongeaient quatre
mois ils écrivent face à l'inconnue que
représentait ce nouveau virus le recours
à l'état d'urgence sanitaire pouvait se
justifier pleinement dans l'urgence du
début de crise épidémique
notre législation est notre cadre
réglementaire ne permettant pas de
prendre les mesures exceptionnelles
nécessaire
mais qu'en est il aujourd'hui après 300
jours d'état d'exception d'état
d'exception ferghana ziari vous trouvez
aussi que de ce point de vue là le
gouvernement va un petit peu trop loin
ça fait bientôt un an maintenant que je
me ferais de fer réduction de nos ailes
libertés publiques et plus généralement
ça fait bientôt un an que je mets ferait
que jusqu'à maintenant ça n'émeut très
très peu de gens puisque de fait nous
avons acté que face aux risques que pose
la liberté individuelle dans un contexte
d'épidémie
et bien finalement la fin justifier les
moyens et qu'il n'y avait quasiment pas
de limites en tout cas et que le virus
devenait le seul critère d'une bonne
politique publique en excluant toutes
les autres variables toutes les autres
crient tous les autres critères qui
déterminent la qualité d'une vie sociale
tout simplement la capacité à subvenir à
ses besoins la capacité à avoir des
interactions sociales et s'éteint c'est
une situation qu'on pouvait déjà
entrevoit puisque souvenez-vous l'année
dernière on avait déjà un débat un peu
malsain quand la chine a montré
l'exemple au monde entier en confinant
la ville de wenzhou est a dire qu'on a
eu un espèce de 2 le débat malsain avec
ceux qui disent regarder une dictature
après tout certes c'est méchant mais
enfin quand il s'agit de contrôler
ça va et vous aviez les avocats d'état
de droit qui répondait manière un peu
étrange en disant mais si regardez la
démocratie libérale peut elle aussi
juguler un virus c'est pourquoi nous
devrions la maintenir
donc cet argument sous-entendez en
substance que si la liberté si la
démocratie ne se suffisait pas à elle
même
eh bien il fallait basse fait dans un
modèle autoritaire pour son jouet
l'épidémie aulnoye je me suis fait
encore mandat ne serait pas un modèle
autoritaire mais de fait depuis un an
nous mangas sont en et policiers pour
empêcher les stones revenir à leurs
besoins nous mandatons des policiers
pour traquer les adeptes de la vie
nocturne donc
alors certes le suffrage universel et
est encore là bien sûr mais le suffrage
universel en lui-même ne dit absolument
rien de la qualité d'un système
politique je crois que ces penseurs
pierre joseph proudhon qui disait que la
démocratie était la liberté ce que judas
est au christ ça veut dire que et bien
il est possible pour les ceux qui sont
qui bénéficie de l'onction du suffrage
universel de prendre des mesures
coercitives et autoritaire et je crois
que malheureusement nous n'avons jamais
posé cette question philosophique
la fin justifie t elle les moyens pour
prendre un exemple volontairement
autorise un peu un peu caricatural
extremis et à dire que si le virus était
le seul critère d'une bonne politique
alors nous devrions tout de suite ou des
prisons sanitaires pour en fermer
brutalement les malades ne faisons pas
heureusement
quoique cette option a déjà été
envisagée quelques instants parce que
nous considérons que les droits de
l'homme et bien constitue un principe
non négociable et que leur suspension
induirait des mots plus grand qu'une
épidémie un parfaitement maîtrisé même
si ces mots ne sont pas toujours
quantifiable je pense qu'il faut revenir
à cette a7 à ce principe philosophique
parce que sinon nous risquons
effectivement d'être empêtré dans une
espèce de d'insécurité juridique
permanente au nom d'un risque zéro
illusoire guillaume bernard vous qui ne
détestait pas l'ordre et l'autorité vous
v comprend et qui ne déteste pas
proudhon non plus pour n'allons plus
grands penseurs anarchiste par ailleurs
l'ennemi de mars
où ça ne devrait pas vous déplaire
l'idée que effectivement on puisse
considérer qu'un moment donné pour
sauver le bien commun et bien en rien
pour les libertés on met des contraintes
à sa liberté
tout le problème c'est de savoir
effectivement si ce qui est aujourd'hui
réalisé c'est le bien commun bien qui
est à la fois le bien du tout de la
société et le biais des parties
l'intérêt général c'est pas le bien
commun aujourd'hui on est supposé
défendre l'intérêt général
alors je convergeraient avec fergane sur
deux points le premier sur le fait que
la vie ne peut pas être réduite à la vie
matérielle à la vie biologique et que
toute la vie sociale économique
culturelle évidemment a son importance
et ça c'est quand même c'est tout de
même passé relativement son silence par
pertes et profits
et puis la deuxième chose c'est
qu'effectivement nos libertés moi
j'aurais tendance à les qualifier de
liberté inscrits dans l'ordre des choses
que ces libertés sont atteintes mais est
ce n'est pas dans le but uniquement de
polémiquer mais je crois que d'essayer
d'approfondir le sujet il me semble que
l'état de droit que fergane défend comme
étant l'instrument qui permettrait
justement de défendre la liberté face à
des mesures liberticides
je suis au regret de constater que cet
état de droit il est inefficace
il me bloque en rien les choses et
pourquoi et bien parce que je crois que
notre société a lancé peut-être un peu
philosophique vous me vous ne couperez
si vous trouvez que je suis trop long
mais notre société repose aujourd'hui
sur la théorie du contrat social sur
l'idée que nous aurions basculer d'un
état de nature un état de société que
lors de ce basculement nous aurions
abandonner une partie
c'est ce que pense et libéraux ou la
totalité c'est ce que pense et
socialistes de nos droits naturels pour
pouvoir obtenir quoi la conservation
pour pouvoir obtenir la sécurité et bien
dans le mécanisme politique qui est mise
en oeuvre aujourd'hui je ne dis pas que
tous nos ministres ont cela en tête
je le regrette peut-être parce que ça ne
mériterait husa traduirait le fait qu'il
ne soit pas tout à fait conscient je
dirais de leur propre philosophie mais
en tout cas pour un certain nombre
d'entre eux je crois que c'est tout à
fait conscient on a tout simplement un
objectif de sécurité en l'occurrence ici
de sécurité n
sanitaires eh bien on est prêt à
abdiquer à détruire les libertés et
regarder demain on va nous proposer
peut-être de nous rendre un certain
nombre de libertés mais à condition
d'accepter qu'il y ait une insécurité
pour les individus une attaque une
intégrité une atteinte à l'intégrité
physique des personnes part peut-être un
vaccin qui deviendrait obligatoire
le coût du passeport sanitaire n'est
sans doute pas totalement oublié
donc voilà c'est le mécanisme
intellectuel de la modernité politique
qui est au creuset je crois de cette
situation que nous connaissons et je
suis au regret de constater que oui nous
sommes dans une situation où nous
perdons nos libertés
c'est le même mécanisme que l'on a aussi
bien dans le le le défi sanitaire que le
défi sécuritaire voulait répondre à une
question posée est ce que c'est en fait
on a l'impression que le reproche qui
est fait au gouvernement c'est de ne pas
aller assez souvent devant la
représentation nationale de ne pas aller
assez souvent devant le parlement pour
demander effectivement un vote sur la
prolongation de cet état d'urgence qui
en soi serait acceptée mais on a
l'impression que le discours syndicaux
politiques c'est de dire les décisions
seront prises mais nous représentants du
suffrage universel on nous demande pas
notre avis est ce que si le gouvernement
allait devant monsieur le devant la
représentation nationale
il y aurait moins de discussions et je
pense que c'est un argument procédural
un peu faible dans la mesure où je
considère à titre personnel que la
qualité d'une mesure coercitive ne n'est
pas miraculeusement augmenté par le fait
que ce soit un parlement d'un score très
démocratique m non c'est à dire que la
démocratie encore une fois n'a pas tous
les pouvoirs moi je suis de ceux qui
comme benjamin constant pense que dans
les matières où la loi n'a pas à
légiférer le voeu de la majorité n'est
pas plus légitime que celui de la plus
petite minorité et donc ça c'est
l'argument l'état de droit at on idée
que la majorité ne peut pas tout donc je
ne crois pas qu'il faille réduire
effectivement la question sanitaire une
question purement procédurale je pense
qu'elle est purement philosophique comme
vient de le dire
guillaume à ceci près que je n'accuserai
pas la théorie du contrat social d'être
alors
jean de l'autoritarisme que nous
subissons parce qu'en tout cas si on
s'inscrit dans la main dans le contrat
social de john locke
bon ben il est il est explicitement
stipulé que la finalité du pouvoir
politique c'est la consternation des
libertés et que la liberté est la
condition de la sécurité or depuis des
décennies on oppose les deux on nous dit
que il faut choisir entre la sécurité et
la liberté ça a commencé déjà que le
terrorisme
on m'a dit que voilà qu'il ya une espèce
de deux conflits et ça c'est une vision
très haut les hyènes lui vaut d'ailleurs
ça c'est amusant parce qu'à l'époque
mails macron dénoncé la permanence de
cet état d'urgence pour le terrorisme
alors qu'aujourd'hui la maintien pour
les raisons sanitaires exact voit bien
que donc s'il ya un paradis social ici
c'est plus le contrat totalitaire de
thomas hobbes qui nous ont dit que le
léviathan serait légitime à posséder un
pouvoir absolu au motif effectivement de
garantir notre sécurité
ce qu'on a toujours pas compris c'est
que encore une fois la liberté est une
condition de la sécurité et ça
malheureusement le constatera quand on
verra toutes les vies brisées on se dit
mais par cette pseudo servitude
volontaire que nous vivons tous ces gens
qui seront reléguées dans une misère
sociale extrême parce que on a opposé là
encore deux notions qui en réalité était
tout à fait à briquet donc c'est la
notion d'état d'urgence qui pose
problème au ps qu'il faut l'encadrer
juridiquement institutionnellement même
l'inscrire dans la constitution avec une
limite précise était là pour que ce soit
cadré que les gouvernements puissent pas
le prolonger comme ça presque à vide
atteint advitam eternam
le problème de l'encadrement c'est que a
priori cet état d'urgence il supposé
répondre à des circonstances
exceptionnelles donc à partir du moment
où on prévoirait des délais qui ne
correspondraient pas à la réalité
il y aurait une une comment dire une
dureté des institutions qui les
rendraient qui les rendraient
inapplicable je je je ne prendrai
finalement même si je ne suis pas un
parangon nécessairement de la démocratie
directe
si nos parlementaires qui aujourd'hui
rue dans les brancards
je dirais été été cohérent il ne
demanderait pas simplement que le
parlement soit interrogé mais que tout
simplement les français soient eux-mêmes
interrogé par le biais pourquoi pas d'un
référendum mais donc si vous voulez je
le problème c'est que on nous a mis dans
une situation on nous a intimidé
c'est à dire qu'on nous a dit que si
nous contestions un certain nombre de
mesures qui étaient prises cédé par
égoïsme et que nous allions d'une
certaine manière et bien contaminer les
autres et provoqué la mort des anciens
etc
je crois que 7,7 ce gouvernement par la
peur est extrêmement malsain voilà alors
nos internautes nos tweets hausse que du
style charyn ce n'est pas l'état
d'urgence et le co vide qui nous la
coved qui nous menace et un gouvernement
qui fait trop peu trop tard louis
actuellement ils bafouent les libertés à
moyen terme il les menace eric sur
youtube stop à cet état d'urgence qui
est en fait une dictature provisoire
provisoire enfin je l'espère a misé sur
youtube aussi si bien plus que ça en
état d'urgence qui se prolonge dans la
durée sans cesse renouvelée est une sans
cesse renouvelée est une dictature
déguisée pour terminer est ce que ça va
changer notre rapport la notion de
liberté
à terme ce qui est en train de se passer
je crois que vous avez parlé de
servitude
volontaire tout à l'heure de soumission
en état de fait d'accepter que ça crée
un dangereux précédent
c'est à dire que nous nous nous sommes
dans l'illusion que la liberté a été
constituée pour les temps paisible et ça
c'est françois sureau qu'il le rappelle
le bas sinon c'est à dire que lorsque
les révolutionnaires français proclame
les droits de l'homme au rang de
principe constitue à l'essai dans des
temps qui était beaucoup plus troublé la
mort était fait partie de la vie la
maladie était la norme la criminalité
était évidemment beaucoup plus élevé
qu'aujourd'hui et donc moi je suis je
redoute cette doctrine qui voudrait que
face à l'adversité
la liberté n'est plus beaucoup
d'importance parce que notre monde est
ainsi fait que des épreuves comme celle
ci je pense que nous en aurons d'autres
et pourtant on remarque effectivement
que l'aversion au risque des sociétés
modernes et c'est un peu le paradoxe de
la prospérité c'est à dire que nous
avons oublié que nous étions mortels
nous avons une espérance de vie qui est
record c'est à dire que nous nous vivons
objectivement l'air la plus prospère de
l'histoire de l'humanité et donc le
moindre risque qui surgit nous fait
beaucoup plus peur qui r c'est à dire
que quand vous regardez l'histoire de la
grippe espagnole qui assure liquide et 2
% de l'humanité ce n'est quand même pas
rien nous n'avions pas pris les mesures
coercitives d'aujourd'hui alors nous
avions fait on a fermé quelques
établissements scolaires mais nous
n'avons pas pris des mesures aussi
coercitives donc c'est un changement de
civilisation en douce qui s'est fait et
je crains en effet que que nous nous
n'avions toujours plus loin devant les
épreuves qui seront les nôtres demain
parce que rien ne dit que notre monde
sera requis mais moins agité qui
n'arrête aujourd'hui newman a retrouvé
votre apport notre rapport la liberté
les modifier on reviendra pas en arrière
on accepter des choses qu'on n'aurait
pas dû accepter et je le crains alors je
ne prendrai pas les mêmes références que
fergani je ne jeûne adouberaient pas la
révolution française sous quintessence
celle de l'expression de la liberté
mais les vents chauds
je l'approuvent lorsqu'il dit que oui
aujourd'hui nous avons été sidérés
nous avons été intimidés et apeuré le
grain qu'une grande partie de la
population n'accepte dans le fond de
situation que je ne qualifierais pas de
dictatorial pour ma part parce que je
trouve que ce serait insultant pour les
institutions roumaines le pouvoir
politique avec la vie c'est le dictateur
était seul hic était là pour sauver le
peuple pour sauver l'indépendance de la
patrie mais que je qualifierais plutôt
de tyrannique c'est à dire que l'on
détourne le pouvoir de sa justification
de sa finalité qui est de la réalisation
du bien commun
et alors la question twitter du jour
était l'état d'urgence menace-t-il nos
libertés vous voyez que 66 % donc
exactement deux tiers la réponse est oui
chez nos internautes et nos tweets
hausse on passe au second débat du jour
qui nous est inspirée à la fois par le
g5 celle de lundi la décision des macros
de poursuivre l'opération barkan
et en même temps la pression exercée par
l'union européenne pour que les soldats
des armées de nos armées soient soumis
aux mêmes règles que n'importe quel
travailleur de l'union européenne
notamment ce qui concerne leur temps de
travail
c'est ce que suggérait il ya quelques
jours l'avocat général de la cour de
justice de l'union européenne
m où ça s'écrit à eux donc je suppose
que ça se prononce comme la hoegaarden m
ou et qui a fait réagir la ministre de
la défense florence parly ce matin
c'était sur europe 1 je vous propose de
l'écouter de travailler depuis des mois
pour expliquer les raisons pour
lesquelles une armée qui est engagée
comme la nôtre dans de nombreux théâtres
qui est une armée en opération ne peut
pas être considérée comme une armée de
temps de paix où les militaires sont
dans des bureaux non ils sont à
l'entraînement il se prépare
opérationnellement pour pouvoir ensuite
être projetés et c'est cela que nous
voulons évidemment préserver
projeté d'ailleurs france paris présente
en ce moment même le troisième sous
marins nucléaires de la france donc on
voit bien qu'elle est qu'elle est très
avancée sur ce sujet et dans le figaro
aujourd'hui il y avait aussi l'ancien
secrétaire général du conseil
constitutionnel jean richdale qui
abondait dans le même sens en disant
cette banalisation du statut militaire
méconnaîtrait la singularité de
l'engagement militaire porteur de ce
bien commun qui est la conscience de
servir la communauté nationale il
ajoutait elle n'irait l'unité de la
condition militaire qui doit être
comprise en termes de disponibilité de
dévouement et de sacrifice et compte
tenu de compensation propres en matière
de congés et de retraite
guillaume bernad j'imagine que vous
trouvez normal que les soldats est un
régime d'exception mais après tout
puisque les nouvelles lois puisque
l'europe puisque le monde après est ce
qu'il est aujourd'hui
est-ce qu'il faut pas arrêter de rêver
tout ça est ce qu'il faut pas tout
simplement abandonné cesser ces vieilles
lunes
bon alors écoutez il est un temps c'est
pas l'historien que vous n'êtes que je
la prendrai ou les non seulement les
militaires avaient un statut particulier
mais il avait même pas le droit de vote
et c'était une mesure républicaine du
19e siècle bon mais n'ont pas jusque là
je crois que l'enjeu ici c'est peut-être
moins quand même la spécificité du
statut et des conditions de
professionnels nos militaires que
l'union européenne qui vient se
permettre de nous donner des leçons
alors que dans le fond la france et
c'est très malheureux mais finalement
que la seule véritable puissance
maintenant que le royaume uni a quitté
l'union européenne est la seule
véritable et seul oui cette véritable
puissance militaire en europe et que
d'une certaine façon nous portons la
charge et humaines et financières et
matérielles de la protection
militaire de l'europe et par nos
interventions sur un certain nombre de
théâtres d'opération de l'europe et
d'une certaine manière de l'occident
aussi dans une moindre mesure que
d'autres puissances évidemment mais tout
de même
alors je lis j'ai lu d'ailleurs dans
l'interview du du ministre de la défense
qui par ailleurs sur cette question-là
avait bien répondu mais elle avait dit
dans cette même interview de dents dans
le figaro si je ne signe si je ne me
trompe pas que et bien il ne fallait pas
opposer l'union européenne et l'otan
moi je veux bien mais parti j'ai
beaucoup de sympathie pour les pays de
l'est leur politique intérieure et
sociétal oui aujourd'hui c'est la
pologne la hongrie et des rats mais il
faut bien reconnaître que leur passé de
pays occupé par l'union soviétique et le
pacte de varsovie les ne les pousse pas
vraiment à soutenir l'idée d'une
véritable défense européenne et qu'il se
réfugie je dirais dans les bras de
l'otan là encore une fois je ne suis pas
un opposant à l'otan mais il faut être
cohérent si l'union européenne et si
certains états pour lesquels on peut
avoir beaucoup de sympathie ne veulent
pas et bien s'occuper de la défense
européenne et qu'il laisse entièrement
la charge à la france de le faire qu'il
ne vienne pas nous donner des leçons
voilà fait rien nous penser que la
france a encore les moyens de se
permettre d'être seul parce que c'est le
cas aujourd'hui dans l'oeuf elle est lé
seul même si emmanuel macron dit on va
développer une force avec
des italiens des polonais justement qui
viendront nous aider mais c'est un doux
rêve ou bas pendant l'instant c'est un
doux rêve mais c'est quelque chose qu'il
faut déplorer c'est à dire que
aujourd'hui les pays européens
malheureusement je crois se comportent
comme des passagers clandestins puisque
de fait les opérations militaires
françaises à l'étranger quelle que soit
leur efficacité et là dessus je ne suis
pas compétent pour me prononcer mais en
tout cas on a un objectif qui est
collectif et européens à savoir protéger
l'europe du terrorisme islamiste pour
protéger l'europe de des conséquences
sécuritaires d'une région d'un continent
africain qui serait déstabilisée
là où je serai moins sévère que
guillaume bernard vis-à-vis de l'union
européenne c'est que nous avons aussi je
crois nous français une part de
responsabilité dans le fait que cette
fameuse europe de la défense n'existe
pas puisque nous avons dit non à la
communauté défense il ya des décennies
il ya aussi des pressions de gars très
souverainiste en oeuvre en france qui
fait qu'on s'est toujours posé pour des
raisons de souveraineté à une
mutualisation des capacités militaires
budgétaire de désarmer européenne donc
il faut aussi je crois qu'on se remette
en question si en tout cas on veut que
nos alliés en europe soit un peu plus
proactifs dans dans la sécurité du
continent européen
sans négliger évidemment le royaume uni
qui même si il n'habite in any plus sur
le l'union dans l'union européenne et
bien habite toujours le continent
européen et donc est concernée par
l'atmosphère sécuritaire du du monde
entier
ceci dit pour revenir effectivement à
cette histoire de réglementation du
temps de travail bon ça c'est vraiment
sûrs parce que pour le coup c'est
vraiment un an je n'attends pas du tout
l'union européenne qui la méprisent le
principe de subsidiarité et c'est à dire
que ces questions là doivent être réglés
la manière la plus décentralisée
possible bon le statut des militaires
français
il regarde les militaires français et
l'employeur qu'est l'état et ç'a eu de
s'arranger sur les conditions de leur
embauche et des modalités de de de
l'emploi dans l'armée ce n'est pas à mon
essaie de dicter ce genre de choses à
mon avis si bien bernard oui là je suis
parfaitement d'accord mais je crois que
il faut bien comprendre qu'entre 54 la
cod qui avait joué et aujourd'hui il ya
quand même une grande différence c'est
la chute du mur de berlin c'est la chute
du rideau de fer
la construction européenne
au départ elle avait une certaine
logique
alors il y avait commises pendant son
fruit runes prospérité économique de
telle manière que les pays occidentaux
qui ne sont pas occupées par ce qui
était devenu le pacte de varsovie que
ces pays occidentaux ne bascule pas dans
le camp de l'est
bon donc les états unis il y avait un
intérêt évidemment et je crois que
philippe de villiers l'a très bien
démontré dans un ouvrage il ya deux ans
en finale
non philippe deville entendants dans un
ouvrage sur le la construction
européenne et l'osce sur le fait de son
monnaie sans répondre sur le fait qu'
évidemment mais c'est assez logique lui
de dénoncer de manière évidemment
catégorie qui scandalisés mais c'était
logique d'une certaine manière que les
états unis aient intérêt à cela le
problème c'est que une fois que
évidemment le mur de berlin est tombé
que l'union européenne s'élargit qu' il
n'y a plus la menace tout de même de
bolchévique soviétique et bien les
enjeux ne sont plus les mêmes
est ce que l'union européenne est est-ce
qu'un certain nombre d'états dans
l'union européenne veulent continuer à
être sous le parapluie plutôt
sympathique il faut le reconnaître de
l'otan où est ce qu'ils veulent
décidément défendre ou non et bien une
civilisation particulière et donc
prendre les moyens de cette défense là
et donc notamment une défense militaire
donc quand 54 on est refusé je dirais la
cee d c'est une chose que aujourd'hui
parce que les circonstances étaient
différentes et parce qu'il y avait là
franchement est-ouest qu'aujourd'hui en
revanche les états où certains états
européens fassent semblant de croire que
l'on puisse être que l'on pourrait être
une puissance géopolitique sans avoir
une armée et donc sans avoir les
dépenses financières nécessaires pour
construire humainement et matériellement
cette armée c'est totalement
ubuesque organisez rescapés une forme
d'arrogance quand dans la france à
vouloir croire qu'elle peut en dehors de
l'europe ou ou avec l'europe en dehors
de l'otan ou avec le temps parfois même
contre l'otan le défend de toute façon
des valeurs comme par exemple la lutte
contre l'islamisme en disant bien même
si on est tout seul on défend même si on
a de lourdes pertes que personne ne nous
aide
et on continue florence parly le disait
aussi ce matin sur europe 1 le sel c'est
la frontière sud de l'europe donc il
faut quand on se bat au sahel ans on
défend en dons sur l'europe
et tant pis si nous sommes tous seuls on
est les plus forts parce que ne faut pas
arrêter aussi avec cette idée qu'on est
une grande très grande nation
non mais on est plus longue date en
série allemand si on travaille je suis
en train de vous expliquer que nous ne
sommes plus en 1914 qu'on a les moyens
de cette ambition officiel on est quand
même sous la présidence d'un remaniement
qui est très européen qui a parfois tenu
des propos qui flirte avec le
fédéralisme et je pense que florence
parly tout à l'heure sur europe1
justement essayer de convaincre
sonia mabrouk oui il y avait des
européens qui appuient la logistique y
avait des forces de combat donc je ne
pense pas qu'il y ait une volonté show
veine chauvine pardonnez-moi de 2,2
d'assumer une étonnante seul du du
continent européen le problème c'est
qu'aujourd'hui il y a trop de
divergences en matière de perception
d'aidé géostratégique le fait est que
entre lisbonne et et varsovie on n'a pas
les mêmes préoccupations sécuritaires se
souvenir que tant qu'il n'y aura pas
cette communauté d'intérêts et cette
conscience collective d'appartenir à une
même aire civilisationnel qui a intérêt
à mutualiser ses forces pour et bien
combattre tel ou tel ennemi ou se
défendre face à telle ou telle agression
l'agression russe d'un côté ou
l'agression islamistes de l'autre est
bien c'est d'avoir sauvé
et de paris à rome on a tout le monde a
le même ennemi c'est l'islamisme
je lis et c'est justement ça l'enjeu de
la présence de la france aux salles mais
je pense que même en france on faisait
steam c'est ennemi c'est à dire que
penser qu'il y ait un tel office us et
européens affectés au figaro mais le
consensus sur le bien fondé des
interventions militaires françaises même
à l'échelle nationale n'existe pas alors
quand vous voulez vous le forger à
l'échelle le européen après pour la
question de l'islam radical moi je
serais plus sceptiques en effet sur la
réponse militaire je pense que l'armée
c'est utile pour pour repousser des
ennemis qui prennent les armes le combat
l'islam radical en trois combats
idéologiques et ça c'est pas une c'est
pas une armée européenne qui va faire
miraculeusement disparaître le problème
idéologique que pose l'islam radical
or ce problème idéologique à mon avis
n'est pas suffisamment pris à bras le
corps pour une raison très simple c'est
que nous sommes encore en paix dans une
lecture un peu matérialiste de
l'histoire qui sous-estiment le poids
des croyants c'est à dire que nous
pensons que l'obscurantisme qui prévaut
au proche et au moyen-orient et le fait
de l'héritage colonial de l'impérialisme
occidental et que donc ce sont les
considérations géopolitiques qui font
que la région ressemble bien à ce
qu'elle est aujourd'hui nous
sous-estimons totalement le poids des
croyances bon à ceux qui pensent que
l'impérialisme occidental est la cause
de tout moi j'aurais quand même
remarquer que le monde musulman où
lorient avec un grand o n'est pas la
seule aire culturelle qui a subi
d'impérialisme
et occidentale de surcroît et pour
autant et bien l'amérique latine ne
s'est pas réfugié dans les religions
précolombiennes pour se libérer contre
l'oppresseur portugais ou espagnols donc
il ya des facteurs culturels et
idéologiques qu'il faut qu'il faut
traiter ces facteurs idéologiques et
culturelles consistant selon moi a
réfuté intellectuellement les fondements
même de la religion musulmane qui motive
aussi les attentats terroristes et les
les violences islamistes qui accable à
la fois l'occident mais aussi lorient
lui-même oui moi je suis parfaitement
d'accord avec ça et c'est d'ailleurs ce
qui pourrait me conduire à contester le
choix parfois des théâtres d'opérations
on va donc au sahel mais en revanche en
arménie on est totalement absente qu'il
dit vous faire simplement c'est bien
pour ça que je le vis
quelques réactions des internautes
cosmos sur youtube l'armée française est
à l'exception d'armes et britanniques
mais vous l'avez dit qu'il ne fait plus
partie de l'union européenne la seule en
europe à être réellement entretenu c'est
une armée de projection qui intervient
principalement à l'extérieur et dans
l'intérêt pour maintenir l'ordre à
l'armée française reste encore
aujourd'hui une fierté
gilles ce n'est pas l'armée qui n'a pas
les moyens de ses ambitions mais nos
présidents qui entraîne l'armée dans des
opérations qu'elle n'a plus les moyens
d'assurer jack depuis quand la france at
elle pu gagner deux guerres tout seul
alain on n'impose plus ses idées par les
armes mais par les idées et par le juste
partage est le résultat de la question
twitter l'armée française at elle encore
les moyens de ses ambitions et bien à
30% la réponse est oui seulement donc
70% par définition non l'armée française
n'a pas les moyens de ses ambitions
merci beaucoup à tous les deux ferghana
ziari guillaume bernard rendez vous
lundi même lieu même heure pour un
nouveau point de vue sur le fil au point
fr présente et heureuse internautes que
vous êtes par guillaume roquette en
chair et en os et d'ici là surtout
n'hésitez pas à dévorer une fille
emmagasine ce week-end sur la couverture
sur versailles autant de la ou du coc
vide
il se passe beaucoup de choses à
versailles au château qui est vide de
visiteurs mais on y travaille beaucoup
pour embellir ce beau château royal du
xviie siècle pour la prochaine
réouverture espère le bon week-end à
tous
[Musique]